دعني احمد في البدايه ان اشير هنا الى
تطور مهم في القضايا المرفوعه ضد رئيس
الوزراء السابق عمران خان ومذكره الاعتقال
بحقه حيث اصدرت محكمه اسلام اباد العليا
حكما يقضي بتعليق العمل بمذكره الاعتقان
الصادره بحق رئيس الوزراء السابق عمران
خان وقال لكنها طالبته بالمسؤول امام
المحكمه الجنائيه في السنباد يوم غد السبت
في اقرب وقت ممكن لكن دون ان يصل متاخرا
لاسيما وان الجلسات السابقه كان يرافق
عمران خان المئات من انصارها الامر الذي
ادى الى وصوله في وقت متاخر الى هذه
المحاكم في موازاه ذلك الفريق القانوني
لعمران خان كان قد تقدم بتسعه التماسات
الى محكمتي اسلام اباد ولاهور
العليا هذه
الاكتماسات يهدف او كان يطالب الفريق
القانوني فيها بمنع رئيس الوزراء السابق
عمران خان كفالات ضد الاعتقال في تسع
قضايا يواجهها من بينها قضيه ما يعرف
بقضيه الهدايا وبالفعل قد توجه عمران خان
ربما كبادر او
كبادره لاظهار انه ملتزم بالقانون توجه
قبل نحو نصف ساعه من الان الى مقر محكمه
لاغور العليا هنا في مدينه لاغور حيث من
المقرر ان يمثل امام القاضي ويؤكد له
حضوره لجلسه يوم الغد في العاصمه اسلام
اباد
طيب يعني هناك تاكيدات على انه سيحضر جلسه
الغت فيما بعد عبد الرحمن هذا هل هذا ما
نفهمه الان
نعم نعم هذا ما اكده رئيس وزراء عمران خان
وما اكده فريقه القانوني
وهذه هي حقيقه هي لنقل الفرصه
الاخيره
وقد استجابت المحكمه للطلبه الذي قد تقدم
به فريقه القانوني وعلقت قرار يعني او
اجراءات اعتقاله ومنعت الشرطه من اعتقاله
الى حين مثوله اذا امتثل يوم غد امام
محكمه المحكمه الجنائيه في مدينه فكما صرح
القاضي القاضي المحكمه ذاتها في جلسه
سابقه فانه سوف يمنع الشرطه من اعتقاله من
المتوقع ان يتم توجيه لائحه الاتهام لرئيس
الوزراء السابق عمران خان في القضيه يوم
غد وهذه القضيه تتعلق باستحواذ عمران خان
وبيع هدايا بطريقه غير شرعيه